nobody's actually ever been able to
measure how bright the sky actually is
in Optical we know in radio frequency
that's the cosmic might break background
nobody's ever been able to measure the
cosmic Optical background because
there's so much scatter light from the
Sun so even HST and jwst they're they're
above the Earth's atmosphere but they
can't do this measurement because
they're still in the solar system and
there's a lot of scattered light from
the Sun so this New Horizons the camera
was not that sophisticated but it was
out there 70 a year from the Sun where
the scatter light from the sun is
reduced by fores of magnitude and so
Mark Postman and toddler went to the New
Horizons people like just point it and
take a picture and see what happens and
so they did that and they mentioned the
cosmic Optical background they got the
first High signal to noise measurement
past the optical background